[Music]
roseann was the hot topic at the TV
Academy Honors event in Los Angeles I'm
more sorry than I can say that all of
these people have lost their jobs like
that's crazy maybe if you make the right
choice
I Rita Moreno stars in the Netflix
reboot one day at a time the network
used Roseanne's cancellation as a
promotional opportunity reminder one day
at a time is a sitcom about a tight-knit
working-class family that tackles
extremely topical social issues in a
smart and innovative way you know if
you're suddenly looking for a show like
that there's other shows and that we no
longer have to support people that are
doing things that are not so great also
honored at the event Samantha bee who
has been under fire for calling Ivanka
Trump the most derogatory word you can
use toward a woman on her show
full-frontal she didn't walk the red
carpet in the media was banned from
covering her speech where Samantha
admitted sometimes I should probably
have a filter I accept that I take it
seriously when I get it right and I do
take responsibility when I get it wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]